let me let me pull up this story which
can kick off this bigger conversation on
the conflict in the u.s because this is
actually kind of
weird it's tragic it's creepy it's weird
we have this from opb alleged killer in
portland's normandale park protest
shooting has been identified they're
saying it's a man named benjamin jeffrey
smith he's being identified as a local
furry
that antifa claims is a nazi because
furries have a known nazi problem
it's very very strange that this is the
story that's coming out but uh just in
reference to this this this story
the um they flat out say
smith's identity was first reported by
anti-fascist researchers
and the oregon oregonian uh oregon live
sm
and the oregon live news outlet
the information we're getting about the
shooting is coming from extremists huh
how can you trust it of course they're
taking quotes from me and they're
screaming that i'm lying and all the
stuff and andy noah is lying i i don't
care what these you know twitter antifa
people think because i think they're
psychotic despotic fascist extremists
when they say that about me i know
they're lying because i know they don't
really believe that we we do a show like
if you look at all the online forums
they refer to me as like a libertarian
centrist you know i flat out say leave
me alone i want to i want to have
nothing to do i get away from the cities
there's no way these people who are in
portland who are going around with guns
pointing them at pointing at people
threatening people smashing property
genuinely believe
the people running away are the fascists
there's there's no way they know they're
lying they know that so i don't care
what they think but this is the the
nature of of the escalation we've seen
so we had you on just before the
election
in 2020 because uh
fortitude ranch
activated and there was a bunch of
stories coming out saying like you know
survival camp activates warns their
their members or whatever this potential
for violence you said it was around five
percent
when i talk to people they have such a
normalcy or optimism bias it can't
happen here
i know i i don't know how
you know to explain to the people who
don't want to believe it maybe there are
people who just don't want to hear it
it's not about they don't believe it
they do believe it but they're just like
please no please no go away if i close
my eyes and ch you know cover my ears
close my eyes it'll just stop it'll stop
you know but it's coming and i think
people need to pay attention to this
because we're at the point now where
there's a group of antifa marching
through the street armed
telling people where they can and can't
drive
in the past not even that long ago
a guy was in his truck and they
threatened him and he pulled a gun so
they pulled him out of his truck and
they beat him
we've seen aaron danielson in portland
he was shot
shot twice in the chest and killed
then bill barr's doj hunted down this
guy michael reinel and they say he got
into a [ __ ] with him they killed him
these antifa people view that as trump's
administration the maga right the
populists
engaging in retribution to me it does
sound a lot like retribution it doesn't
matter though it doesn't matter which
side you're on it doesn't matter if you
think you're right it's just at a
certain point you need to wake up to
realize this stuff is happening it's
happening with increasing frequency
and you know so so to escalate this to
where we're going now that the elections
are coming up midterms
the democrats lose power in in in the
house and
in the senate then republicans are going
to go off the wall i don't believe most
republicans will go off the wall i
believe the trump maga america first
types are going to be like
revenge and retribution and if people go
out and vote in the primaries and get in
real politicians not establishment crony
bad idea or no idea republicans i guess
rhinos
if actual new incumbents come in i'm
sorry new candidates wipe out push out
the incumbents we might actually see
some real action from the republican
party
but then you're going to see antifa
losing their minds
then you're going to be getting into
2023 which is the presidential primary
season with donald trump coming out
saying we will win
antifa is going to go crazy and then you
have 2024 an election year and then
donald trump wins so then what happens
trump 2.0
madness
so what i'm wondering is is what level
can you take it to next because it was
already an existential threat right
aliens so where else do you go and we i
mentioned this before we start going on
air right maybe that's when we see the
aliens come in and calm all this down
because
honestly i i don't know where you can go
other than more
of the i mean i'm speaking verbage right
because the way they explained it last
time
and and interestingly enough
putin even used that word uh as he
explained what was going on uh trying uh
existential threat accidental threat yes
and he used that word it's interesting
how it always right gets picked up and
passed around and used in so many
circumstances uh right it becomes the
the phrase of the day but
so i just don't know how
how much more nuttier or how the
language can get any more over the top
then
they'll find a way right because
they truly believe
that it's the worst possible thing that
can happen i remember
you know back when he was elected
and
uh
the girlfriend i was that i was with at
the time
and
she lost her mind i said listen
you know how many presidents
administrations i've lived through so
far in my lifetime
they come and they go they come and they
go and the world doesn't end it's
everybody who doesn't come and go in
washington that we're really going to
try to do something about the
administrative state man they need term
limits yes and and then
every
people if you know it i get it it's so
important to you if you haven't lived
through a bunch of these but when i was
in school i was literally taught the
next thing coming our way was an ice age
yeah
that's what i was taught as a kid i
believed it
i thought the next great thing that
happened to mankind was an ice age and
i've lived through all the others of
about this there's a great video um i
don't have a po i don't know if i could
pull it up but i think it's carl sagan
talking about the um the the global
cooling
and he's like scientists believe a great
ice age could be coming and it was like
from the 70s you know and then science
changes right absolutely you know people
panic for a lot of different reasons
i think the issue we're facing now is
there was a point at which
american society hard forked
split into two distinct entities
for a while they were close enough
together where it was an argument saying
like what are you doing over there we're
talking over here now it's so far
divided
it's just i think i figured out we're
young across the chasm i was thinking
about a lot about this there's there's
multiple ways to think and to problem
solve and to come to conclusions one of
them is the scientific way to do it
which is you acquire evidence over time
and that once you get enough evidence
you can confidently say this is what i
believe is happening then there's
warfare where you have no information
about what the hell is happening you
know that there's artillery firing from
over there there's a machine gun nest
now you have to make a decision and
people are in the war mine state they're
afraid they're terrified probably by
design so they're making these
split-second decisions without
information and acting like
these are supposed these are like solid
scientific
ways to to look at things and they're
not you're you're half i think you're
half right i think they're lacking
information i think they're in a war
mind but i think it's by choice
we have the story from axios democrats
tune out national news during biden era
look at this democrats just spiked
straight down this is exactly the
problem i've talked about with you know
the obama activists the i'm sorry the
anti-war activists voting for obama the
moment their guy gets in they turn off
so now what's happening is democrats are
no longer paying attention to news
they're now below republicans but
they're still acting on politics they're
still engaging in conflicts they're
still pushing and and they're they're
still active
they're just willfully ignorant now i
think what like what you said man people
feel like this this is gonna
there's too much emphasis being placed
on the political candidate it's to be
afraid
or
to have total faith that your candidate
is going to solve save the situation is
ridiculous we found that out with obama
turning his back on people and to think
that this candidate is going to destroy
the world is also ridiculous the
system's built around i mean i
understand an executive can be kind of
crazy and can do stupid stuff but we
have plenty of safeguards no exactly and
and
so we're we're definitely going to see
right so if everything seems to play out
the way it looks because of the
overreach in some of the ridiculousness
of how covet has been handled
you you probably see you know the
democrats getting a good shellacking in
the midterms right
now the back peddling is starting they
understand they're they're
losing the independence the people are
really getting sick and tired of this so
this is gonna unravel to a certain
degree then like tim said so that just
brings about uh blm and antifa now being
in the streets more than what we've seen
them over this past time it intensifies
and intensifies and then who knows it
should come to some kind of crescendo
for you know 2024 in the presidential
elections well you're familiar with the
strasshaw generational theory right yeah
so um
by 2028 should be the end of the fourth
turning
so uh don't be surprised if i i believe
we we you know we're in it for around
what 20 years or so yeah is when it
starts kicking into high gear and
surprise surprise that's 2008.
the start of this economic crisis which
escalates dramatically causes look i
think the economic crisis really is a
big
uh precursor to everything we're seeing
you get a young generation who can't get
find jobs uh people my age getting out
of college all of a sudden
unable to work as dishwashers something
i experienced i remember i went to a
small tiny hole in the wall diner and
there was a guy in his suit applying to
be a dishwasher for 10 bucks an hour and
i'm like some scraggly dude and a beanie
like how's just looking for some side
cash man this guy needs it more than i
do
you get these young people who then say
why is my life so bad and they blame the
one percent
this drives them into this this quest
for meaning
unable to do work unable to pursue their
passions
that escalates over 10 years with them
getting into activism turning news into
activism putting politics in every
corner of every aspect of our lives and
now we're at this point today
uh so eight years after the crisis you
get donald trump donald trump being a
symptom people are saying we're tired of
this we want something to change the
other side believing trump was a fascist
and literally hitler going insane
all of that has continued to escalate i
think occupy wall street you get the
financial crisis which leads us to
occupy wall street which brings the this
critical race theory activism into the
fray with all the activists in new york
who then engage in violent tactics black
block tactics it escalates i suppose you
could even go back further than that and
figure out where all this stuff started
when they you know uh was a
glass-steagall gets repealed or whatever
and then how this all begins
but i think the big spark like something
broke 2008
then what 2020 the end of this period of
strife a hard time
which is economic crisis which is
political crisis which is street
violence
the night is always darkest before the
dawn
but uh 2024
i think is going to be bad i think this
year is going to get bad already the
activism is getting nuts this story is
crazy i think 2023 is going to get bad i
think 2024 will be worse because trump
will end up as the republican nominee
what's what are the democrats going to
do biden i have no idea
2025 donald trump is inaugurated what do
you think january 20th 2025 is going to
look like in dc you think january 6 is
bad wait till january 20th 2025 for the
second inauguration of donald i got to
say
i think there's no way trump is gonna
even have a chance at being president
i'll go on record now i could be totally
wrong maybe i'll eat my words i didn't
think he was gonna win last time either
with hillary clinton uh i was shocked
but i it's like the same kind of
surprise attack thing in military you
don't do it twice they they're ready for
it now it's going to be total media uh
what do they call what the time magazine
article call it shadow campaign
fortification yeah the total media
fortification of uh their candidate but
i think that's a key factor here over
the past six years the corporate press
has lost a lot of credibility right even
with normies
they have for sure oh yeah you've always
kind of been dialed into it i'm
wondering if like the average person
well it seems like even the democrats
are kind of tuning out are they going to
crank crank up their viewing again when
it looks like trump is going to win a
second term or has the corporate press
actually lost some of the credibility
that used to have i don't know i see
seems to me like it's crumbled quite a
bit well it's going to really hinge on
who's going to be the candidate also
democratically right
i mean well let me yeah
that's kind of andrew yang crazy trump
will win prospect so that's that's going
to be huge thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time